gaben secret are you no sir that's not
to strike you dead Winslow
hi everyone I'm Joel Mears on the
editor-in-chief of Rotten Tomatoes and
today I'm here with the director of the
lighthouse
Robert Eggers and one half of the
madness at its center Robert Pattinson
welcome guys thank you so first question
I'm going to throw to an audience review
that came in for your film over the
weekend from a guy named Alex I won't
give you his last name but he said I
don't understand what the [ __ ] is
happening here and I'm just wondering if
you can you can help you guys have a
great score actually the audience score
is really high but can you help alex is
Alex out well what is happening here in
a lighthouse I mean I think that that's
a fair question to ask I think that even
people who enjoy the movie I hope that
they are exiting the theatre asking that
very same question but you know you
don't I mean it's just it's just two
guys going crazy in a lighthouse
I think the audience ends up in the same
place that both the characters I mean
think about how like twisted his
character becomes trying to discover and
understand what's going on in the movie
so it's only fear you're adding folk
horns and things to drive us insane the
entire time
yeah do you remember the first time you
read the script cuz I know you wanted
something weird did it satisfy that itch
weird as such I just kind of I'm always
very trepidatious said the right word
about playing English people in period
dramas because I think when you are
starting on acting in England
you're basically that's that's it and it
seems like if you do one then you're
kind of locked in for a while yeah and
so I was always and that's kind of why I
went to America died pretty early on
I wanted to play Americans and I wanted
to and I do feel very English but I kind
of didn't necessarily want everyone to
I mean identify me as English but then
with this I'm a reading I said this
doesn't really count as a period drama
at all it doesn't kind of a period piece
like it is a period piece but it's like
it just seemed like it was using the
period elements to make it seem alien
rather than to make it seem familiar I
feel that most period things they have
to kind of check a lot of boxes first of
all and it kind of puts me off but this
is Phil the kind of colloquialism of it
and the kind of specificity it made it
just feel very unique more than anything
one day it's pretty John realest yeah I
won't talk about genre second why was
Robert the person the person to play you
from who else could possibly do it I
mean I think Rob carries a lot of
mystery with him I don't know if it's
you know the way your eyes are set but
but no he and and like you know when Rob
was saying that he'd turned down a role
that I offered him that he's so smart
about the roles that he chooses and he's
looking to work with Oh tours and want
to be Oh tours like myself and and take
on challenging work I mean we you know I
think you did use the word weird but I
think but but you also said that it
wasn't challenging and and that is what
makes Rob such a great brave actor is
that he's he's looking for challenges
all the time so you know whenever you
see a film that he's in it's cold it's
quite staggering because because it's
always different from the last one and
and he is taking these these big risks I
just mentioned to him and again that I
rewatched lost city of Z and there's a
moment when he just sees a dead fish and
says extraordinary four times and I
thought [ __ ] that performance is
extraordinary you know and I mean that's
an incredible performance in this film
watched yesterday the buzz coming out of
the theatre second time
as Rob you just knocked out of the park
but you're matched sort of an intensity
by Willem and I'm wondering what was it
like working with Willem in such closed
quarters when the scripted sort of
demanded this kind of madness I mean
it's kind of impossible not to but he's
kind of I I mean there's a couple of
different is when you read the script
the first time his part could be so dark
likes so kind of venal and that there's
definitely a world where it could be
just horrifying and there's just
something so mysterious about William
they just no matter no matter who they I
love like his performance in the Nick
hey slow down well like paying the worst
place in the world and also and has that
kind of intensity and terrifying focus
and then he has the ability to just
switch so fast on a dime to make to make
it like an inmate something a joke
immediately you never quite know he
stand and he's very very good at doing
that but like and also it's funny like I
was doing we we were to read this
rehearsal stuff and and I could see I
was kind of going okay I see kind of a
warm today I'm gonna hold back I'm gonna
when I've got my big moments I'm gonna
try
shock him and I just will win over
whatever you throw it will them he so
immediately can absorb what you're doing
and then to completely recalibrate his
entire performance on the dime and again
and suddenly display like and then to
consume you he can just make himself so
huge afterwards and that no matter if
you start screaming and shouting
attacking him you just just can he can
eat you evident throughout who you are
back into your own face
[Music]
of you guys just kidding I guess
blackout drunk crazy in the film I
should say was that fun to direct and to
watch happening if it was shot yeah I
mean it's incredibly fun to work with
just with these two actors who are up
for anything game for anything like you
know they they signed up to this knowing
that they were gonna be like punished
well you know we there's been talk about
Rob wanting to punch me in the face
[Music]
what's that it's okay if you did if I
did it but like but you know we are
shooting a scene it's raining the rains
not reading in this close-up so we have
to get the fire hose so that we can see
that the rain and the close-up but
because as you know when you get cuts
the photos and and you know and that's
making it harder for Rob to do the
action so we have to do take after take
after take but I you know and if you do
want to watch me head it's
understandable and you want you know we
didn't use the final take just you know
so that you know but but Rob if we
needed three more he would have done it
and he would have done it harder than he
did the last three because that's the
kind of actor he is and so that night
where you're blackout in Europe you're
dancing in your fugitive blackout go
straight there you're hugging your you
know it's so all the stages of a massive
night at the ends of the netting
hungover but what did you do to prepare
to get in that frame of mind worried
were you drunk were you what was the
situation there well we should end
sequence I think pretty much yeah yeah
and so it's kind of rare for this movie
yeah and so it's kind of from the
dancing thing I mean it was like a lot
of energy expenditure but it's kind of I
don't know something it's just a lot of
the script no matter had like even the
kind of abstract nature of a lot of it
all I always just felt very cohesive to
me I kind of knew where was come right
even if I wouldn't be able to define
explicitly lay exactly what it was you
could really feel
the tone is in the writing and then and
then I think we'd shot quite a lot by
that point and so I kind of got where
how you'd be feeling and lot of the song
at what I'm saying it's very beautiful
so that's kind of but so much of the
stuff I mean it's kind of you you never
really get a part where it has these
kind of these 180 turns all the time
like they're kind of from that dancing
scene to the fighting afterwards I mean
it's kind of it was so specifically
written in the script and even to the
stance which they were gonna be boxing
each other and anyone who's shootin it
up - whoo - fine we did one take where
the fight was just serve kind of just
fighting and we were like I just need to
need something else needs to be straight
please be stranger please put
immediately any kind of chase
immediately take two bears just grabbing
two sticks
[Laughter]
no that was done that was it I say
there's no improv in this movie but I
suppose that was that was ya know would
take it but you know but yeah I mean and
they were really punching each other a
lot of women what am i sweat to this day
I was just putting his middle finger
like this is right in my ribs
no so you had some other co-stars in
this movie sort of following on from
black Philip II went to Siegel's yeah
how was that like to direct animals
again and what was it like working with
the seagulls the the goat you can't
train a goat so don't ever make a movie
with a goat and a major role film
students don't do it but the seagulls
were incredibly well trained they came
from the UK like Rob classically trained
British actors hiding they're doing main
accents and but they their names were
lady [ __ ] and John
and we were they were fantastic I don't
think I ever had any interaction with
this ego I just I had a one interaction
with a rubber chicken you're part of
this sort of new wave of horror
filmmakers at least for your first film
who came out the gates but he's
incredible you know I'm thinking
Jennifer can re master and I feel like
you guys went away and chatted and said
for our second films in 2019 we're just
gonna screw you up and we're not gonna
give you anything that looks like a
genre film and I wonder what what genre
is this movie and I guess the question
is what what are you guys doing with
sort of stretching the elasticity of
genre at the moment yeah I mean first of
all that that meeting of the three of us
did happen and it was and I don't know
okay of course anyway are you look I
don't know III bow down and pray to the
altar of genre everyday because it was
able to get this movie and the other
movie made you know what genre is it I
really couldn't tell you like I I think
that a lot of ways it's it's like the
many ways it's like the literary genre
but weird tale like the work of
Blackwood mr.james
Arthur Mackin but because of a lot of
the sort of theatrical traditions that
it draws from that doesn't quite fit
either but I've had journalists and and
other people who get my intentions and
our intentions who said that they see it
as a war movie and they actually think
it's scary I don't think it's scary
you know I hope it's like it's slightly
dreadful at least but though I don't but
I don't mind if it scares people you
know and and really like we need people
who call whatever they want and we need
to have these labels so that we can talk
about things the only thing that bothers
me is when my my my fellow nerd brethren
feel like you need to have
exact list with exact boxes checked to
call something something you know it
does it doesn't matter when the iron
late Iron Age ended in the early Middle
Ages began they've been academia they do
have the same kind of like yeah
arguments but we're all just trying to
find words and ways to talk about
stories that we like so we just to be
fine Robert Pattinson
how do you describe it if I was to ask
you do you find it scary do you find it
I mean I've oh you're probably just
gonna be like wait oh my you're wrong
now because it's kind of there's lots of
like grotesque uh zyf in it but it
doesn't relief I don't think it's scary
as such but it's kind of my appeal to me
the most in the script was that sort of
humor where you mean I remember the
first time I read and I wasn't entirely
sure if how much you even knew it was
funny or which bits because I was like I
didn't renew what it was supposed to be
and like but it kind of reminded me of
like kind of been well stuff you're kind
of on Shan Andalou like the kind of when
you it's sort of there it's sudden
images of which they're just really like
really frightening all the sudden but
it's not it's not kind of really
concertedly trying to build tension to
have a specific release that you're kind
of it's sort of the tension is built up
and then you're just part of the tension
that goes like it's a tense but it's
kind of it also like a kind of dark dark
dark dark comedy like I mean it's kind
of less sort of surreal comedy as good
as it is hilarious just before we wrap
you for your next film the Northmen do
we know what genre that's going to be
yeah it's
a revenge drama whatever you know very
two years and see how we describe them I
mean I don't even you know until it's
that was leaked not announced so I don't
even know I don't even know if I gonna
make it official
I hope I hope I do all right and rub it
your next film tell us anything about
that are you excited to take on the
Batsuit oh yeah very very thanks notice
too still far enough away to not be
nervous there's still a fun part for me
okay thank you guys so much the
lighthouses in theaters now it'll be
expanding check online to see if it's
coming to you guys coming close to you
thanks again guys thank you so much